et avec nous pour le match des idées en
direct sur public sénat rno benedetti
bienvenue vous êtes rédacteur en chef de
la revue politique et parlementaire
professeur associé en histoire de la
communication à la sorbonne et vous êtes
l'auteur de ce livre le progrès est il
dangereux dialogue contre les idées
reçues
virginie le gars est également avec nous
bien venu virginie chef adjointe du
service politique de paris match merci à
tous les deux arnaud benedetti est ce
qu'on peut nous expliquer un petit peu
ce qui se passe bruno retailleau veux
absolument mettre au plus vite sur la
table cette question de la primaire
christian jacob n'en veut pas en tout
cas pas tout de suite officiellement
pourquoi qui jouent la montre pourquoi
parce que la primaire c'est un
traumatisme c'est les républicains
beaucoup considèrent que la primaire est
à l'origine de leur échec ce qui n'est
pas d'ailleurs forcément vrai en
l'occurrence mais en tout cas mais ça a
laissé des traces dans l'appareil
politique républicain il y a aujourd'hui
finalement de ligne qui s'opposent il ya
une ligne qui normalement la ligne qui
est défendu par celui qui n'est plus
chez les républicains mais auquel un
certain nombre de républicains pensent
qu'ils aient xavier bertrand qui
considère que lui finalement la la la la
la
l'élection présidentielle c'est la
rencontre un d'un d'un d'un individu et
d'un peuple que la tradition d'ailleurs
la vème république et puis in een qui
considère que justement aujourd'hui les
choses ne sont pas suffisamment claires
et que seule une consultation soit des
militants soit au delà des militants
permettra de départager comme l'a dit ce
matin d'ailleurs françois xavier des
amis sur ce même ligne et c'est aussi la
ligne de gérard mercher tafer virginie
legay un scénar sénateurs s'agacer hier
dans le jdd en off d'un tout sauf
retailleau d'une partie des heller
pourquoi ce tout sauf retailleau est ce
que c'est à cause de ce calendrier que
lui veut accélérer que d'autres ne
veulent pas parce qu'ils attendent les
a lille je l'attends xavier bertrand oui
alors il ya d'abord l'idée que le
décider maintenant serait prématuré que
les français ont bien d'autres choses à
penser qu'il faut au moins attendre
comme le propose le christian jacob
les départementales et régionales du
mois de juin et que on y verra plus
clair à ce moment là et puis il ya aussi
l'idée que bruno retailleau représente
une ligne trop dur trop raide trop trop
à droite et courent dans les rangs de l
air effectivement ce mot d'ordre tout
sauf retailleau en tout cas bruno
retailleau lui est extrêmement sensible
à cette fronde qui est en train de se
dessiner contre lui mais insiste
beaucoup pour dire que le futur candidat
ce qui c'est vrai ne s'impose pas
aujourd'hui que ce soit xavier bertrand
bruno retailleau ou valérie pécresse qui
est arrivée dernière ont même rachida
dati une personne ne s'impose lui il
part du principe qu'il faut départager
des candidats et que seuls les adhérents
et les sympathisants pourrait le faire
et là je rejoins ce qui a été dit à leur
part arnaud bedetti ce n'est pas la
primaire de 2016 qui a provoqué l'échec
de françois fillon françois fillon a été
désigné avec une majorité une une
participation extrêmement importante à
la primaire de 2016 il a été désigné
sans 1800 ambiguïté mais personne ne
pouvait prévoir que françois fillon
serait rattrapé malgré la faire il fait
un très bon score
bien sûr il fait 20% après le chemin de
croix qu'il a il a subi pendant des mois
et des mois subi ou en tout cas on
essaie pendant des mois et des mois mais
personne ne peut lier ce qui s'est passé
après à la prime est en elle même la
prime rôles elle même a permis de
désigner un candidat que les
sympathisants on voulait reste tout de
même une question est ce que le candidat
choisi par les sympathisants et les
adhérents et celui qui incarnerait une
ligne plus plus générale c'est là où
xavier bertrand lui défense ont un point
de vue très différents il dit les
sympathisants vont vouloir un candidat
du rpt un candidat qui est qu'ils
défendraient une droite un peu raide
mais le grand le la grande majorité des
français voudront une liste qu'on
appelle les sympathisants de droite sans
que ce soit des wheat le peuple de
droite voudra une ligne plus plus
modérée ce qui n'est pas dit parce que
emmanuel macron est là pour la ligne
modérée et donc
on est en train là de d'avoir un débat
qui n'est pas si papa près d'être résolu
le problème de fond c'est comment on
desserre l'étau comment dessert le tour
d'un côté avec un rassemblement national
qui a capté une partie aussi de cet
électorat qui est l électorat
républicaine notamment dans les classes
populaires il voir dans une partie des
classes moyennes et comment on desserre
l'étau par rapport à un emmanuel macron
qui on l'a vu maintenant depuis trois
ans a réussi à rallier à lui disons un
électorat de centre droit ou même
parfois de droite qui se retrouve
notamment dans ses positions parfois les
murs et gallienne telles qu'il les
écrans
le vrai problème finalement au delà de
la question de la méthode qui consiste à
trouver un candidat et à départager des
candidats c'est de savoir quelle sera
l'offre politique qui sera l'offre
politique qui permettra de faire cette
synthèse entre finalement ce qui était
une partie de cet électorat c'est à dire
cet électorat de centre-droit qui
représente en fait ce que l'on appelait
dans les années 90 et 2000 l'ancienne
udf et une droite plus sociale plus
souverainiste c'est ça la vraie
difficulté
on s'est trouvé une équation le attendre
les régionales de gençay tard quand même
de toute façon c'est tard je vous
rappelle que les dernières le lait les
primaires qui se sont déroulés en 2016
se sont déroulés dans le dernier
semestre 2016 donc il n'est pas trop
tard en effet c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui
il ya quand même deux il ya deux
paramètres qui pèse beaucoup c'est la
gestion de la crise sanitaire et des
conséquences économiques politiques et
sociales de cette crise on est con n'est
pas aujourd'hui véritablement on verra
ce qui va se passer en 2021 et ensuite
en effet vous avez des élections qui
sont des élections intermédiaires qui
sont les élections régionales et les
élections départementales qui
permettront de voir d'ailleurs si un
certain nombre de postulants à cette
candidature présidentielle sont validées
déjà par les électeurs sur leur propre
territoire
alors il ya la question du calendrier
puis il ya la question évidemment des
personnes christian jacob en un peu dit
ne semble pas faire l'unanimité chez l
air on va demander un sénateur membre de
cette famille politique on accueille
dans ce match des idées g
bachère bienvenus vous êtes sénateur et
l'air de l'oise merci d'accepter de
jouer le jeu du match des idées
politiques ce soir disons le vous ne
faites pas partie des grands fans de
christian jacob
je ne suis pas dans les grands fans moi
j'avais voté guillaume larrivé qui est
lui-même a eu un positionnement
d'ailleurs un peu variable on va dire ça
comme cela mais ce qui est important de
dire et c'est que christian jacob a
quand même fait une chose importante la
famille politique après les élections
européennes et est très morcelé très
divisée il a essayé de rassembler tout
le monde sans exclusive et l'a plutôt
bien fait mais maintenant on est et où
il a gagné les élections municipales et
ça il faut le dire je pense qu'il peut y
aura peut-être se targuer d'une autre
victoire aux élections départementales
et régionales mais devra vont pas la
peau de l'ours
simplement ça ne fait pas l'élection
majeure de la vème république qui est
d'élections présidentielles et là ils
mangent leadership lui manque à
christian jacob pour que vous soyez un
grand fan pour reprendre le frère
question non il manque de leadership et
de puissance des idées et d'imprimés
voilà on va dire les choses quand
ric-rac homme parle je ne sais pas qui
il l'entend
c'est ça le problème il est en revanche
un homme de synthèse et cela est
important à un moment où il va falloir
mettre effectivement en place soit une
méthode de départage soit une méthode
qui fera en sorte qu' il ya une des îles
à sion sable s'il n'y a pas besoin de
faire de primaire quel que soit
d'ailleurs
départage fait mais ouverte peu importe
mais je ce qui est certain c'est
qu'aujourd'hui on attend une méthode et
un calendrier et le calendrier il n'a
cessé d'être repoussée parce qu'il
croyait en françois barois et on et qui
devait être le messie or il se trouve ne
pas l'être
donc c'est un peu bizarre comme espérant
de dire il ya des statuts aujourd'hui
qui voudriez voir une primaire dont fo
qui raconte comme une histoire
aujourd'hui et peut-être que la première
des choses à faire moi je le suggère
très simplement c'est que tous les
hâtif candidat à l'élection
présidentielle se rencontrent au mois de
janvier pour parler de cela
aujourd'hui chacun va sur sa radio
chacun
va de son communiqué de ses soutiens
pour dire voilà une méthode voilà il en
faut il en faut il n'en faut pas je
pense que c'est très bien que le
mouvement se rencontre car je sais
qu'une seule chose du peuple de droite
c'est qui les aspire à skier qu'un seul
candidat et que nous gagnons comme cela
l'élection présidentielle alors il ya le
peuple de droite et puis il ya le parti
l air est ce que vous auriez jusqu'à
dire qu'il y a deux clans au sein de
votre parti un clan retailleau et un
clan jacob bertrand pas tout à fait
c'est à dire que bruno retailleau quand
vous connaissez aussi bien que moi
il propose beaucoup il travaille
beaucoup et il dit on ne peut pas être
vides y compris dans la méthode
donc il propose une méthode il a le
mérite de proposer ce n'était pas la
seule méthode possible mais il a le
mérite de proposer il faut parfois
proposés et parce qu'aujourd'hui on est
dans le vide alors le vide ce n'est
jamais une façon de créer de l'espoir de
faire du débat le vide c'est la pensée 0
et bien non il faut avoir une pensée à
la fois sur les idées pour le pays à la
fois pour notre famille politique et son
fonctionnement
c'est ce que fait me bruno retailleau
qui avait renoncé rappelez-vous à se
présenter à la tête du parti
parce que et c'était l'accord qui avait
été passé et candidat putatif à la
présidence du parti politique ne devait
pas être candidat à l'élection
présidentielle
c'est une des raisons pour lesquelles
bruno retailleau n'y est pas allé la
seconde c'est qu'il ne voulait pas la
division de la famille et donc je suis
certain que bruno retailleau ne cherche
pas à la division de la famille mais
cherche à montrer que cette famille
pense et qu'elle propose
christian jacob pour l'instant il est
plutôt sur la pause 0 match est resté
avec nous et n'hésitez pas à vous
manifester si vous souhaitez à nouveau
intervenir
virginie legay cette idée de se
rencontrer de tous ces candidats
potentiels qui pourraient se rencontrer
en janvier pour parler se mettre
d'accord c'est une idée mais encore une
fois est si urgent pourquoi ne pas
attendre les prochaines élections qui
vont avoir lieu en juin voire un peu
quel est le bilan des municipales des
sénatoriales et départementales sur
quelle force la droite peut compter et
voir à ce moment là comment le paysage
se dessine pour quoi ils sont pressés
d'être valeur par park acheter mais ils
sont pressés parce que personne ne
s'impose et que tout le monde essaye de
s'accrocher à un calendrier à quelque
chose moi je voudrais quand même dire
mots de xavier bertrand qui lui se
montre extrêmement opposé à la primaire
mais xavier bertrand il n'appartient
plus à l air d'où sa difficulté de se
positionner par rapport à un parti qui
l'a quitté et puis en plus xavier
bertrand qui dit mais moi j'ai ma propre
primaire qui sera l'élection au conseil
régional
ils oublient que la précédente fois
lorsqu'il s'est présenté et qu'il a
gagné il a gagné suite au retrait du
parti socialiste et ça m'étonnerait que
le parti socialiste retire à nouveau
cette fois ci donc les cartes seront un
peu plus compliqué lui va se retrouver
face à un front national qui s'appelle
maintenant rassemble national très durs
très très très solidement implantés dans
cette région là les cartes sont un petit
peu moins facile pour lui
donc attendons de voir ce que tout ça va
donner avant de voir dans quelle
situation les uns et les autres vont se
retrouver
moi il me semble qu a pas d'urgence et
quand j'entends le sénateur mâcheurs dit
christian jacob c'est la pensée 0 le
calendrier 0 j'allais bien dedans dans
votre intérêt à tous n'allez pas trop
vite
attendez vous avez bien le temps la
précédente primaire comme l'a rappelé
monsieur benedetti elle a eu lieu huit
mois avant franchement est ce que est ce
que les français ont la tête à ça
aujourd'hui
pas du tout et puis j'ajouterai une
dernière chose qui moi me rendrait plus
inquiète c'est qu'une partie de
l'électorat de droite est clairement
identifiée chez emmanuel macron et va le
rester
donc il va falloir traiter avec un petit
pré carré les deux bouts de l'omelette
sont un peu partie en fait chez vous
malheureusement monsieur ma chère donc
vous allez devoir traiter avec un centre
dur et ça ça met un peu plus difficile
avant de vous donner la parole arnaud
benedetti jérôme bascher pourquoi être
si près c'est est ce que ça ne donne pas
une image un peu morcelé de votre parti
ce qui est dangereux quand même j'ai
admiré l'oxymore un centre dur mais
c'est intéressant comme concept mais ça
ou bien qu'on est dans une force est
perturbé non ce que je dis c'est que il
faut on peut discuter aussi de la
méthode et se mettre d'accord c'est pas
la dernière minute
on se met d'accord sur une méthode c'est
vrai c'est ça qui est important donc il
faut et c'est pour ça qu'une rencontre
entre les uns et les autres me semble
une façon non pas de se mettre d'accord
sur un point final c'est de se mettre
d'accord peut-être sur une méthode et
que chacun discute à peu dans le blanc
des yeux
ça me semble assez important mais moi je
ne suis pas du tout sûr l'analyse qui
vient d'être fait vraiment elle me
semble assez éloigné de aussi de ski et
le terrain aujourd'hui l'oubli c'est que
xavier bertrand a battu marine le pen
l'a pas battu n'importe qui à l'élection
régionale
il a battu marine le pen n'oubliez
attentive retrait de la liste de
fonctions évoluées d'accord change tout
bon ça devrait on verra bien mais ne
change pas tout parce que c'est un des
sujets majeurs de l'élection
présidentielle et c'est pour ça qu'elle
ne sera pas candidate à l'élection
régionale et donc il ya bien des enjeux
régionaux locaux qui ont un impact sur
l'élection présidentielle j'en reviens
j'ai pas dit que richard jacob s'était
pas la pensée 0 qui changeait comme
étant un grand chiraquien avec une
pensée film des territoires je dis
simplement qu'il n'a prime pas c'est un
petit peu différent je voudrais rendre
hommage je connais bien je vais très
longtemps christian et c'est vraiment
quelqu'un qui a des convictions cher
mais aujourd'hui le parti n'a prime pas
sur ses idées il a besoin
christian jacob parce qu'il a des amis
fort à nerfs de rassembler autour de lui
il à gérard larcher
bruno retailleau damien abad les
présidents d'edf le président de la rfef
de régions de france aujourd'hui
le président de la mrc quand même tout
ça c'est des gens de la famille et l'air
et tous ces gens là ont beaucoup de
puissance et il a on a du mal
aujourd'hui à rassembler un peu tout le
monde serait bien qu'on rassemble tout
le monde et avoir un collectif puissant
qui impose peut-être la bonne méthode
arnaud benedetti pour conclure sur ce
chapitre écoutez vos christian jacob
puisqu'on parle de lui c'est le plus
petit dénominateur commun qui permet
aujourd'hui
recoller d'une certaine manière les
morceaux dans une famille qui était
quand même particulièrement balkaniser
du fait notamment de la défaite de 2017
ça c'est une réalité mais aujourd'hui le
drame existentiel des républicains c'est
que ils sont forts territorialement ils
l'ont démontré aux élections municipales
il y a de fortes chances qu'ils le
démontrent à nouveau lors des élections
départementales et lors des élections
régionales
mais il y a un il y à il y a quelque
chose qui manque
il ya deux choses qui manquent c'est la
ligne politique dit en effet n'apparaît
pas aujourd'hui très clair pour un
certain nombre d'électrices et
d'électeurs de droite ça c'est le
premier de le premier point le deuxième
point ce qui manque en effet ensuite
c'est la capacité d'avoir quelqu'un qui
puisse incarner cette ligne politique
alors moi je ne suis pas sûr que ça soit
le président du parti qui soit le mieux
placé en l'occurrence à la limite il
vaut mieux avoir un président de parti
qui ne soit pas lui même candidat
cette élection pour mettre en oeuvre la
bonne méthode en l'occurrence qui
permettra de trouver un moment donné la
solution qui sera la solution adéquate
mais je pense très franchement
aujourd'hui que c'est encore très tôt
en l'occurrence c'est que on est dans on
est en pleine crise sanitaire
on a des élections départementales et
régionales dans six mois
en principe l'opinion publique est très
loin d'être cristallisée sur l'enjeu
présidentiel dans le moment donc
j'aurais tendance à dire il est aussi
d'une certaine manière de bonnes
politiques d'attendre en l'occurrence de
voir comment les choses vont se décanter
pour ensuite vint trouver la solution
qui sera la solution en tout cas là la
plus la plus prometteuse alors qu'on
puisse discuter sur une méthode
ça me paraît en effet important pour un
parti politique mais encore une fois il
ya quelque chose qui est très important
et qui reste ancré quand même dans le
chalet dire dans la dans la psychologie
des électrices et des électeurs de
droite en tout cas les plus engagés
c'est que pour eux à tord ou à raison la
machine des primaires a constitué une
machine à perdre d'ailleurs elle a
constitué une machine à perdre aussi
également du côté du parti socialiste
donc il y aura aussi vrai seulement une
réserve vis-à-vis de ce dispositif si ce
dispositif voyait le jour
merci gérant de ma chère d'avoir
participé à ce match des idées non va
continuer mais on vous laisse
merci infiniment de vous êtes prêté au
jeu ce soir car c'est à droite encore
que certains aimeraient bien voir
edouard philippe lhomme candidat ce
matin dans le brief politique de france
info nil à la trousse nous disait par
exemple jean françois copé ne se privent
plus de dire tout le bien qu'il pense de
l'ancien premier ministre et qu'il voit
comme une piste pour la droite en 2022
le maire de meaux a même plaidé sa cause
au bureau politique des républicains
avec cet argument vu l'état de nos
ressources humaines il n'est pas
indispensable de fermer des portes
l'intéressé lui se garde bien de
confirmer ou d'infirmer la moindre de
ses intentions ce week end il a quand
même fait la une du jdd mais uniquement
pour parler de l'organisation du
dépistage massif au havre et ce matin
c'est fièrement aux côtés d'olivier
ferrand qu'on l'a aperçu pour promouvoir
son opération de dépistage pas une once
d'hostilité à l'égard de l'exécutif est
même plutôt un discours très amicale moi
je voudrais souligner la très bonne
coopération entre les services de l'état
et l'ensemble de la communauté urbaine
du havre
nous avons travaillé en bonne
intelligence comme nous avons travaillé
en bonne intelligence lorsque le pic
épidémique de cette deuxième vague s'est
produit avec les services de l'état avec
les hôpitaux publics et les cliniques
privées avec les médecins libéraux cette
se travaille en bonne intelligence il
nous permet d'obtenir des résultats je
crois virginie legay certains à droite
aimeraient beaucoup qu'ils s'émancipent
de la macro ni on en est très très loin
là bas on en est très très loin
probablement parce que lui-même ne tient
pas et qu'il n'a cessé de faire de sa
loyauté vis-à-vis de maquereaux sa force
et d'ailleurs les français lui en sont
très reconnaissants et il ya des
sondages très flatteur pour lui mais
très flatteur parce qu'effectivement il
a été un premier ministre qui a fini par
je rappelle qu'au départ il était
totalement inconnu du grand public il a
fini par imprimer une marque et une
marque bien à lui fait de second degré
d'un peu de recul d'un peu d'humour et
en même temps d'une grande fermeté mais
il n'a cessé aussi de dire qu' il était
loyal au présent la république et moi je
le vois mal opéré une métamorphose aussi
brutale qui voudraient qu'ils passent de
ce qu'il est aujourd'hui c'est à dire
l'ancien premier ministre manuel mac os
avec lequel ils continuent à échanger
en son adversaire le plus féroce et le
plus irréductible contre lequel il se
présenterait ou alors il faudrait qu
emmanuel macron ne puisse pas se
représenter
le président de la république sortant a
lui même dit qu éventuellement s'il
n'était pas en capacité de représenter
enfin il a ouvert une porte très large
j'allais dire presque pas par excès de
précaution mais on voit pas très bien
mais c'est vrai que tout peut arriver on
voit pas très bien ce qu'aujourd'hui
l'empêcher de se représenter
donc les chances que edouard philippe se
présentent à la place d'un emmanuel
macron sont aujourd'hui très mince mais
les chances qui se présente contre
emmanuel macron me semble inexistante
il ferait partie des rares dont la cote
de popularité ne tournerait pas la tête
alors oui seulement mais enfin ceci dit
la condition de faisabilité d'une
éventuelle candidature d'edouard
philippe comme l'a rappelé très
justement virginie legay c'est le fait
que emmanuel macron ne se représente pas
alors à partir de là en effet dans cette
hypothèse là il peut constituer un
recours pour la droite il a plusieurs
avantages c'est que d'amour sun il est
très incertain à droite en il à droite
la droite enlèvement fin il faudra jouer
il faudra quand même aussi gérer la
macro ni et problème c'est que la lame
acronis est un archipel aussi on le voit
bien c'est assez composite donc en effet
il va séduire une partie de la macro ni
la macro ni qu'ils se trouvent
c'est là et qui d'ailleurs est souvent
celle qui appelle en effet
éventuellement à sa candidature en
l'occurrence pour certains d'entre eux
il ay là il a trois avantages c'est un
élu local ça s'éteint c'est un point
extrêmement important dans le contexte
actuel le deuxième le deuxième le
deuxième avantage c'est que c'est un des
rares premier ministre est sorti de
matignon avec une cote de popularité qui
est une cote de popularité positive la
tête haute c'est un deuxième c'était un
deuxième montage il un troisième
avantage c'est que dans l'histoire du
mandat de la macro ni finalement il
apparaîtra au fur et à mesure que les
mois passeront comme la partie du monde
à où il ya eu un certain nombre de
réformes qui ont été effectués par ce
qu'on peut imaginer que maintenant le
temps des réformes contenues de la crise
sanitaire que l'on traverse va être
beaucoup plus difficile donc il a ses
trois avantages
ceci dit
après il y a chez lui disons des
aspérités qu'il ne faut pas cacher des
aspérités pour une partie de l'électorat
de droite parce que pour une partie de
l'électorat de droite il est celui qui
d'une certaine façon aussi a trahi sa
famille politique pour rejoindre
emmanuel même s'il l'a rejoint faut-il
sur souvenir après l'élection
présidentielle il n'appartient pas à la
macro ni historique deuxième aspect
c'est que au delà il a soufflé gunilla
cette distance qui est cette élégance
naturelle qui parfois peut en effet
séduire mais il a été aussi il a fait
preuve d'une certaine forme de rigidité
il faut jamais l'oublier notamment au
moment de la réforme des retraites
il a été l'un des points en tout cas de
crispation dans le dispositif
oui mais c'est un peu revenir on lui
rappellera savez comment ça se passe
inévitablement
donc il ya tous ces aspects
objectivement aujourd'hui l'hypothèse
d'une candidature d'edouard philippe me
paraît en effet relever véritablement de
l'hypothèse pas de candidature en
revanche peut-être un atout maître pour
la macro ni encore plein de of sorti par
neil à la trousse ce matin sur france
info des confidences de poids lourds de
la macro ni edouard philippe est
beaucoup trop orgueilleux pour
s'abaisser à la trahison edouard veut
arriver comme celui qui sauve macron sa
mission et de ringardiser la droite y
compris ceux qui veulent être candidats
à la comparaison est terrible à chaque
fois le maire du havre est un actif
précieux un élément essentiel de la
réélection je pense que emmanuel macron
effectivement aurait tort de se priver
du soutien d'edouard philippe si il
devait briguer un deuxième mandat
pour autant toutes les pensées qui sont
près d elle doit féline ne me semble pas
tout à fait correspondre au caractère
douleur philippe muller philippe dans le
fond il est assez simple il était à
matignon il a fait ça à plein temps et
même plus qu'à plein temps il a fait ça
avec énormément d'énergie
parfois une certaine rudesse et une
certaine dureté il s'est même parfois
opposé à emmanuelle macouin il voulait
que les choses aillent plus vite et plus
fort
mais une fois qu'il est parti il est
parti sans regret et les mardis au à rio
ave je pense il le dit et en tout cas
tout tout tout son entourage le confiant
il est heureux dans ce qui fait il a
récupéré samedi son indépendance
politique sont assises
kale je ne suis pas sûr qu'il soit
traversée d'arrière pensées compliqué je
ne suis même pas sûr que ça fasse partie
de son adn après qu'il ait un rôle
décisif auprès d'emmanuel macron dans le
cadre de la campagne 2022
on verra bien mais oui emmanuel macron y
aura du mal à s'en passer manuellement
croate bien besoin de ce signal très
fort qu edouard philippe
on voit tout un électorat de droite et
reste dans son camp en quelques mois
avant de parler il a besoin en effet
aussi d'avoir un grand élu local il en
manque cruellement dans son dixième
c'est fait et leurs philippe rapporté en
tout cas cette cette ressource là il y
un dernier point quand même sur edouard
philippe et sur sa popularité il faut
jamais oublier qu'un capital de
popularité ne fait pas un capital
politique il y a plein d'exemples dans
l'histoire de la vème république
deux personnages politiques eu un très
fort capital de popularité qui n'ont pas
pu forcément transformé ensuite en
capital électoral je pense notamment à
michel rocard
si derrière ou simone veil et michel
rocard qui est un des exemples
d'ailleurs keim exciper edouard philippe
un mot de yannick jadot pour terminer ce
match eurodéputée europe ecologie les
verts mais une voix écolos un petit peu
dissonante au sein de son parti hier
dans le grand jury rtl lci le figaro
il a validé la 5g j'ai la conviction que
cette technologie peut éventuellement
servir la transition écologique dit il
tiens tiens c'est déjà pas tout à fait
la ligne d eric piolle quant au futur
porte-avions à propulsion nucléaire
bah pourquoi pas elle nous contraindront
naturellement dr alors ça c'est une
question complexe
la france si elle un porte-avions elle
continue de jouer dans la première
division au niveau mondial sur la
capacité à exporter une flotte
ok donc ça peut être un élément positive
arnaud benedetti c'est vraiment un
électron libre ce yannick jadot au sein
d'europe écologie les verts c'est quand
même pas comment entendre la 5g
c'est bien et le porte avions nucléaire
pourquoi pas oui il prend à revers
quelques fondamentaux historiques et les
verts
vis-à-vis de la critique concernant la
technologie l'antimilitarisme mais il y
a eu toujours chez les verts des
personnalités qui ont essayé d'arrimer
ce courant politique dans une forme de
réalisme et la plupart du temps ils en
sont sortis
la plupart on s'en sortit c'est à dire
que tous ceux qui ont essayé
in fine et à l'intérieur de ce courant
de d'importer une de ce colloque ce
qu'on peut appeler une culture de
gouvernement
finalement son parti ensuite sous sur
d'autres rives le reste ça sera la
trajectoire de yannick jadot
le problème des verts sait que ils ont
grandi électoralement mais qu' il
conserve à l'intérieur de la de leurs
appareils
une forme de culture qui est un peu une
culture groupusculaire c'est à dire ou
de luttes de factions entre minorité qui
ne se mettent pas d'accord et qui ont
tendance parfois à expulser ceux qui
pourraient être disons les plus les plus
à même éventuellement de les porter dans
un débat politique qui serait un débat
politique qui les arriverait une forme
de réalité et ça c'est la difficulté de
ce courant c'est une difficulté
historique et alors l'autre difficulté
c'est qu'ils sont forts territorialement
le voit lors des élections municipales
ils sont plutôt fort aux élections
européennes mais on voit que l'offre en
tout cas qu'il n'arrive pas à présenter
à l'élection présidentielle montre bien
que là ils ont une vraie difficulté
virginie legay yannick jadot eelv a
incarné une écologie consensuel moderne
pragmatique on n'est certainement pas
pour la solution de tout interdire tous
punis
il est très loin d'aider des positions
prises par certains maires sur les
sapins qui seraient des arbres morts ou
sur la 5g et je sa compagne isabelle
saporta d'ailleurs dit pendant cette
période extrêmement fructueux de toutes
ces déclarations des merveilles quand
est-ce qu'ils arrêteront de nous faire
de nous donner une idée à la con par
jour moi c'était son expression et c'est
ça donc yannick jadot lui il est
vraiment dans une démarche beaucoup plus
positive je rappelle que pendant là lors
de la précédente présidentielle
il était pour même une candidature
unique de la gauche les finalement hissé
il s'est présenté puis s'est retiré en
faveur de benoît hamon parce qu'il
estimait benoît hamon avait plus de
chances de réunir les résultats on dit
autre chose mais il il est pour quelque
chose de fructueux il est certainement
pas sur la ligne des verts qui sont donc
quand même dans une logique de machine à
perdre deux divisions de querelles
intestines haye qui n'en finissent pas
qui a jamais assisté à des réunions
internes des verts on est sortis en
s'arrachant les cheveux ça dure des
heures on se dispute pour des petites
choses qu'on ne s'entend pas au tout le
monde est passionnément séquençage
induit encore bien sûr et on voit bien
qu'il est assez isolés face à des verts
qui pour certains ont été élus dans des
grandes villes au municipal ce qui était
une grande première et ce qu'ils
représentaient pour eux une accession à
une visibilité très forte mais cela ils
ont un petit peu la grosse tête et l'un
des maires comme eric piolle franchement
disent des choses parfois un petit peu
ahuri sentent pour ne pas dire plus donc
lui il est assez loin de tout ça si vous
avez trop trop vite quoi bein pas
préparé en tout cas à la gestion
j'allais dire la gestion de d'un niveau
d'une grande collectivité comme ça il
gère un peu comme il gérait les
divisions intestinale de leur parti mais
c'est pas comme ça et là ils vont devoir
soit soutenir
yannick jadot à contrecoeur et pour
l'instant il ne semble pas tellement
résolu malgré le score assez honorable
café yannick jadot aux européennes
soient se trouver un autre candidat
franchement à part les ambitions des
rings piol je ne sais pas s'ils
récupèrent le rassemblera beaucoup de
monde derrière lui
voilà donc les écologistes et il
pourrait peut-être si c'était trop
divisés et trop incapables de se mettre
derrière une vision grande nature un peu
consensuel raté une occasion qui se
présente qu'il est très clairement à eux
parce qu'on voit bien liste des
déceptions qu'engendre emmanuel macron
du côté de l'école et écologique donc là
il ya vraiment un terrain électoral
vacants à prendre y'a de quoi ferrer on
s'arrêtera là pour aujourd'hui mais
évidemment suivra ça de très près dans
les semaines et les mois à venir merci à
tous les deux d'avoir participé à ce
match des idées très politique on se
retrouve
demain à 18 heures et à 22h30 dans un
instant auditions publiques l'invité ce
soir laurent berger pardon le leader de
la cfdt demain 7h30 bonjour chez vous au
rayonnement de chimie recevra damien
abad président du groupe et l'air à
l'assemblée nationale je vous souhaite
une excellente soirée sur public sénat